[Music]
this is a very versatile fit tonight and
I wish it was Versace it's not Versace
illusion yeah birthday girls Asia O'Hara
and her RuPaul's Drag Race sisters
stepped out for a television Academy
event Monday night in LA hey racers the
show is up for 12 Emmy Awards at this
year's show including outstanding
reality-competition series what would it
mean for the show to win for the season
you were on um you know for me
personally it would be great it would
fit will be the biggest thing I've ever
been a part of in my life it was right
on trend with what a lot of people deal
with on a day to day basis and it's
right on trend with a lot of the social
issues and social triumphs that we have
today in America so I think now is the
best time ever for RuPaul's Drag Race to
win because I think it's the most
accurate and relevant season we've had
today you ended the season having some
words with Roo at the Reunion you see me
walking out no I'm not walking out I
learn how to act around people and have
a deal with have you guys been able to
chat about that since you know we have
not I think you know as professional
adults you know when you you know have a
conversation with someone and you say
your piece and you don't always agree
you don't always not everybody always
ends up on the same page and I think
when I hope a lot of people take from
that is it's okay to have a difference
in opinion you say your part I will say
my part and as professional adults we
will go on with our lives to continue to
you know live and grow next to one of
them here we are filming the Vixen reach
out to you after seeing how you defended
her at the reunion well not really reach
out to vixen tonight as most of us do
talk on a regular basis
and I didn't kind of filter and a little
bit before it aired just so she knew but
you know it was not to what I think it's
important for people to know is it was
not me sticking up for the Vixen it was
me voicing my opinion about how we
accept and touch and hold one enough but
it wasn't me
Asia sticking up for fixin a person it
was me as a representative and an
ambassador for the community explaining
to people why it's important to at least
attempt to see and understand different
sides of different situations you just
sticking up for Asia's point-of-view
correct what is next for Asia um well I
am working on a lot of new things
creatively a lot of new content and a
lot of new art and you know every day I
am searching for new and better ways to
hear myself and my art and my point of
view with the rest of the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
would you revisit butterflies at all at
the future work the world to where start
September 5th so get a ticket and find
out oh we love a queen with the t's yes
now would you go back and do it all
again sign yourself up for all stars are
you kind of one and done you know I'm
neither I'm definitely not one and done
like if if drew came and tapped me on my
shoulder now and said hey we're leaving
tomorrow for all-stars that'd be like
but you know my answer might be
completely different in three or six or
nine months so I love drag race I love
any opportunity to showcase myself and
what I have to present to the world so
I'm definitely not against it I'm deaf
but I'm definitely not a one-and-done
you got to do the work the world to our
first yeah there we go
well congratulations
[Music]